diese Paste hat mich durch meine
Studienzeit gebracht und das Gericht
heißt Panel Tonno episelli und Zwiebeln
sind auch mit dabei die geben wir
zuallererst in eine Pfanne mit Olivenöl
dünsten die ein bisschen an bis sie
glasig sind währenddessen können wir die
Nudeln ins Wasser geben ich frage jetzt
mit den Erbsen auch direkt weiter die
geben wir zu unseren Zwiebeln wenn diese
angedünstet sind die sind gefroren das
ist wichtig nimmt gefrorene Erbsen weil
meine Mama hat mir sogar gebracht ich
habe mich auch nicht weiterentwickelt
mit dem Rezept das bleibt genauso wie es
ist jetzt gehen wir noch ein Schlückchen
Wasser dazu und geben dafür den Deckel
drauf wenn die Nudeln halt fertig sind
nehme ich den Deckel ab und gebe ein
zwei Dosen Thunfisch hinzu jetzt noch
mal extra viele Olivenöl wirklich lasst
euch dabei Zeit es gibt keine andere
Soße und gehen mit Salz und Pfeffer dran
Nudeln abschütten und zu Erbsen und
Thunfisch hinzugeben jetzt gut
durchmischen als ich klein war habe ich
dann immer probiert die Erbsen durch die
Penne zu schießen was auch funktioniert
guckt euch diesen Traum an das ist auch
so eine Pasta von der man nicht wenig
essen kann für mich gehört jede Menge
Parmesan rüber auch wenn es eine Pasta
mit Fisch ist und jetzt steht dem Genuss
nichts mehr im Weg
boah so